there are two schools of thought some
Entre entrepreneurs believe that mentors
and coaches are a huge integral part of
their life I know that I've had
spiritual mentors Financial mentors
career mentors I've had mentors in every
area of my life I see you as a mentor uh
on the other end there are entrepreneurs
who believe they're self-made that you
don't need mentors you don't need
coaches you don't need to listen to
anyone's advice where do you sit on that
and how do you help young people
navigate that today because I think a
lot of people are stuck trying to figure
it out or they're not doing either
properly as well the second group is
stupid
but just be clear okay that was very
radically uh I just want to be clear
they may confuse the
fact that
um they may have good instincts they
have to make their own decisions they
can be
um independent thinkers that might do
controversial things in order to be
successful that all is true okay that
all is true
but
the perspectives gain the learning uh
the wisdom that is gained the
open-mindedness the power of stress
testing your ideas I say that I think
everybody's uh to be successful should
be assertive and open-minded at the same
time people ask well what does that
merely mean it means the you have to
believe you have to understand and at
the same time you have to doubt and pull
out and get the questions so that you
stress tested and you're learning yes
yes and so there's a great power in
getting the other perspectives you know
a triangulation for me is the key to
success one of the keys to success
triangulation I mean get the three
smartest people that you know who will
care about you yeah and but will
disagree with you we'll stress test you
and and and have those conversations and
I like to have them disagree with each
other yeah so I'll bring them into a
room and we'll have a conversation yeah
and then okay do the back and forth you
want to learn about anything like I have
big initiatives and where I don't know
anything and I have found that if I
follow that approach by getting the best
experts and I do that I can go into
things with the with the guidance so
it's so obviously stupid I think or so
obviously beneficial to be able to draw
upon the best thinking and then not to
just blindly believe so when I say it be
assertive and open-minded at the same
time don't just follow okay do the back
and forth here's the disagreements and
then resolve the disagreements it's an
extremely powerful approach